okay this is let's begin with breaking
news from kyrgyzstan where security
services are saying they've foiled what
they're calling a coup attempt at least
15 people have been detained including
politicians and former officials will
al-jazeera zane bastravis in the capital
bishkek with more on what's happening
what more do we know about what's going
on
well rob what we're hearing is coming
from an official government statement
that was released
by the security service they say that in
tandem with the minister of internal
affairs they carried out a series of
raids in which they arrested 15 people
who were planning an armed coup in the
post-election period now this comes just
less than 48 hours before the country is
due to go to the polls
for parliamentary elections and the
reports suggest that what was going to
happen is that these were organizers
that were going to try to amass as many
as a thousand people in the days after
the election to contest elections not in
the halls of government but on the
street as is very common
in kyrgyzstan now what we were hearing
is that they were planning to have
clashes with police and security
services and try to use that as an
excuse to uh overthrow violently
president sader jabara's government
ironically president sadha japara of
just last year rose to power in similar
circumstances this country has seen
three violent revolutions in the last 15
years and upcoming parliamentary
elections are something that the
government is trying to use to show that
they are the adults in the room that
they are the government of stability and
this uh report of a foiled coup plot it
has to be said is happening at a very
convenient time just days before the
parliamentary vote
let's to talk about those upcoming
elections i mean where does the
opposition for example stand with regard
to to the elections
well
you know one thing that's happened
during the campaign season is that
president sader japarov uh he is
extremely popular but he's been
criticized for cracking down on those
that are against him as critics any sort
of political dissent as well as cracking
down on press freedom but the fact of
the matter is in the rural as well as
urban areas he is still the most popular
political leader currently in the
country
blinded by a childhood disease dastan
bekeshev struggled with depression at an
early age
the pursuit of knowledge he says saved
him and led him to a career as a lawyer
once a member of the party overthrown by
kyrgyzstan's president sadhar japarov
the acting mp is now running for
parliament as an independent
his campaign slogan i see the truth a
play on his disability suggests he has
not lost his sense of humor
and perhaps a jab at the current
leadership he may be blind but even he
is able to see the people's real
problems
social media is just like tv
you can be recognizable you can make
appeals from social media but you will
not lead your voters to the ballot boxes
that is why personal contact the moment
when you are chatting with your
potential voter it betters the chances
that this voter will come and vote for
you
in a system that has for years run on
political favoritism dastan walking the
beat makes him a rare breed
the election for a new parliament is
only a few days away but walking around
the capital bishkek you wouldn't be able
to tell this is the lowest level of
public activity this country has ever
seen before a vote now that may be down
to a nationwide case of what some
experts are calling political fatigue
this is after all the fourth round of
polls this country is conducting in a
year
political heat from opposing forces is
also noticeably milder dissent has been
muffled by allegations of corruption
opposition activists and leaders are out
of the country or in prison
and front runners that are likely to
fill parliamentary seats largely back
the president
japarov has not been as heavy-handed as
previous leaders but has cracked down on
political opponents intimidated critics
and passed laws to weaken press freedom
things he said he would not do
public promises that make him popular
his critics say are a cover for the same
corruption of past governments
many fear the elections will be followed
by hostility
i have no doubt that's going to happen
history's shown us that such dictators
as the current government wait for
elections only to strengthen their
vertical power as soon as they have
enough support as soon as they have the
parliament and the courts in their hands
they will intensify their fight against
us
voter turnout is going to be an
important indicator of the health of
democracy in kyrgyzstan
and after years of ballots cast out of
fear under pressure or for payment turn
out this time is expected to be
extremely low
zambasravi al-jazeera bishkek